GOING ALONG WITH HIS 2020
ELECTION LIES.
KEMP DOES HAVE A BIG NAME
STUMPING FOR HIM, FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
LET'S GET TO CNN'S POLITICAL
DIRECTOR, DAVID CHALIAN.
TELL US WHAT TO WATCH FOR
TOMORROW IN GEORGIA.
>> ALISON, YOU WERE BRIGHT.
GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP, THE
INCUMBENT GOVERNOR, TARGETED BY
DONALD TRUMP, BECAUSE BRIAN KEMP
RIGHTLY AND CORRECTLY CERTIFIED
THE LEGITIMATE ELECTION OF JOE
BIDEN IN THE BATTLEGROUND STATE
THAT HELPED PROPEL HIM TO THE
PRESIDENCY.
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN TELLING
HIS LIE ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION
EVER SINCE AND THAT MAKES KEMP
TARGET NUMBER ONE.
DONALD TRUMP MAY BE IN FOR A BIG
LOSS HERE TOMORROW IF THE
PRE-ELECTION POLLS ARE CORRECT.
YOU MENTIONED THE TRUMP VERSUS
PENCE FACTOR.
TONIGHT PENCE HAS THAT RALLY FOR
KEMP, TRUMP IS HOLDING A
TELL-RALLY FOR PERDUE.
AS YOU KNOW, THEY ARE ON OTHER
SIDES OF THIS.
THEY'RE TRYING TO CARVE OUT
THEIR OWN POLITICAL TURF INSIDE
THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY IN
ADVANCE OF 2024.
LOOK AT THIS STATEMENT FROM
DONALD TRUMP SPOKESPERSON TODAY
TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES" ABOUT
MIKE PENCE.
NOW, DESPERATE TO CHASE HIS LOST
RELEVANCE, PENCE IS PARACHUTING
TO RACES HOPING SOMEONE IS
PAYING ATTENTION.
THAT'S PRETTY DIRECT AND SNIDE.
SO NO LOVE LOST DESPITE PENCE'S
LOYALTY TO DONALD TRUMP.
THE OTHER THING WE'RE WATCHING
ARE EARLY VOTING TURNOUT
RECORDS.
TAKE A LOOK ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE, PRE-ELECTION PRIMARY VOTES
CAST THUS FAR, IN 2018 IT WAS
172,587.
IN 2022, 406,388 REPUBLICAN
PRE-ELECTION PRIMARY VOTES.
RECORD SETTING.
AND, BY THE WAY, DEMOCRATS ARE
COMING OUT TO VOTE EVEN THOUGH
THEY DON'T HAVE A VERY
COMPETITIVE CONTEST AT THE TOP
OF THEIR TICKETS FOR GOVERNOR OR
SENATE RACE.
IN 2018 WHERE THERE WAS A
COMPETITIVE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY,
151,204 PRE-ELECTION VOTES CAST,
IN 2022, IT'S NEARLY 300,000,
NEARLY DOUBLE WHAT IT WAS FOUR
YEARS AGO IN THE PRIMARY SEASON,
ALISON.
>> DAVID, REALLY INTERESTING
STUFF.
LOOK AT THAT LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT.
LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS IS
FASCINATING.
AND YOU'RE FOLLOWING A
DEMOCRATIC RACE FOR SONG IN
TEXAS AND HOW ABORTION IS
PLAYING INTO IT.
>> YEAH, THIS IS A FASCINATING
RACE.
IT'S A RUNOFF BETWEEN THE
INCUMBENT MODERATE ESTABLISHMENT
DEMOCRAT, ONE OF THE VERY FEW
DEMOCRATS THAT STILL PORTRAYS
HIMSELF AS A PRO-LIFE DEMOCRAT
IN THE CONGRESS.
HE DOES HAVE SPEAKER PELOSI'S
BACKING AS THE INCUMBENT.
BUT THE MORE PROGRESSIVE
CHALLENGER RUNNING WITH BERNIE
SANDERS AND ELIZABETH WARREN.
WE'LL SEE IF THE PRO-ABORTION
CANDIDATE CAN FIRE UP ENOUGH
PROGRESSES TO OVERCOME THE IN
DUMB BENT IN THIS RACE AND WHAT
THAT MAY MEAN FOR DEMOCRATS
TRYING TO HOLD ONTO THE DISTRICT
IN THE FALL, ALISON.
>> DAVID CHALIAN, WE'LL BE
WATCHING, AS WE KNOW YOU WILL
BE.
THANK YOU.
>> THANKS.
>>> SO LET'S DISCUSS FURTHER
WITH CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR
SCOTT JENNINGS, WHO SERVED AS
SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO PRESIDENT
GEORGE W. BUSH.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN GEORGIA WITH BRIAN KEMP.
SO HE HAD TO TODAY TRY TO
EXPLAIN HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
DONALD TRUMP, AND HERE IS WHAT
HE SAID.
>> I HAD A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH MIKE PENCE, I HAD A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
I'VE NEVER SAID ANYTHING BAD
ABOUT HIM, I DON'T PLAN ON DOING
THAT.
I'M NOT MAD AT HIM.
I THINK HE'S JUST MAD AT ME AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I CAN'T
CONTROL.
>> OKAY, SO NUMBER ONE, WHAT DO
YOU HEAR IN THAT STATEMENT?
AND, NUMBER TWO, IF KEMP WINS
BIGLY, AS PRESIDENT TRUMP USED
TO LIKE TO SAY, DOES THAT CHANGE
DONALD TRUMP'S KINGMAKER STATUS?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, FOR BRIAN
KEMP I THINK THE KIND OF
AUTHENTICITY YOU HEARD IN THAT
ANSWER IS THE WAY HE'S RUN HIS
CAMPAIGN, AND IT'S IN LARGE PART
WHY HE'S WINNING SO BIG HERE.
HE DIDN'T TRY TO CONTORT
HIMSELF, HE DIDN'T TRY TO PLAY
SEMANTICS GAMES ABOUT HOW THIS
HAS GONE DOWN.
HE JUST ACCEPTED THE REALITY,
LEANED INTO IT, STATED HIS
POSITION.
AND I THINK THE VOTERS HAVE
REWARDED HIM FOR IT.
GOVERNORS RACES ARE OFTEN ABOUT
COMPETENCE, LIKABILITY,
AUTHENTICITY AND THE FUTURE AND
KEMP HAS JUST REALLY DONE GREAT
IN EVERY SINGLE CATEGORY.
REGARDING THE FUTURE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, I THINK THAT
WAS THE SECOND PART OF YOUR
QUESTION --
>> WELL, THE KINGMAKER STATUS,
DO YOU THINK HIS KINGMAKER
STATUS, DONALD TRUMP'S, HINGES
ON THIS?
>> WELL, I MEAN, LOOK, I THINK
HE'S STILL EXTREMELY INFLUENTIAL
WITH REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
IT'S JUST IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE HE RAN UP AGAINST SOMEBODY
WHO FIGURED OUT HOW TO SOLVE THE
EQUATION.
IT DOESN'T MEAN DONALD TRUMP
ISN'T AN INFLUENTIAL PERSON
ANYMORE.
KEMP HAS HAD THE BENEFIT, TOO --
AND SOMETIMES IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY THE WAY YOU CAN EXPLAIN
SUCCESS IS BY HAVING ALL THE
RIGHT ENEMIES.
DeSANTIS HAS THIS RIGHT NOW.
KEMP HAS HAD ALL THE RIGHT
ENEMIES.
HE DEFEATED STACEY ABRAMS, STOOD
UP AGAINST SOME OF THE
CORPORATIONS IN GEORGIA IN 2020,
HE STUCK TO HIS GUNS ON THE
GEORGIA ELECTION LAW THAT A LOT
OF THE NATIONAL LIBERAL
ESTABLISHMENT CAME DOWN ON HIM
FOR.
SO EVEN THOUGH DONALD TRUMP WAS
MAD AT HIM, HE THEN CULTIVATED
SOME OF THE RIGHT ENEMIES THAT I
THINK SIGNALLED TO REPUBLICAN
VOTERS, BRIAN KEMP REALLY IS ONE
OF US, DESPITE DONALD TRUMP'S
OPINION.
SO DOES IT TOTALLY THROW OUT HIS
KINGMAKER STATUS?
NO.
DOES IT SHOW A WAY TO STAND UP
TO DONALD TRUMP, YES.
AND DOES IT SHOW THE RIGHT WAY
TO RUN A CAMPAIGN WHEN YOU HAVE
THIS DYNAMIC, ABSOLUTELY.
PEOPLE SHOULD STUDY THE BRIAN
KEMP MODEL.
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO HEAR WHAT
SOME REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS ARE
SAYING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AND
HOW HE'S CONDUCTING HIMSELF IN
2022.
BASICALLY THEY'RE CALLING HIS
INVOLVEMENT HIS PERSONAL
VENDETTA TOUR AND ONE OF THE
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT IT IS
FORMER NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR,
CHRIS CHRISTIE.
HE SAID THIS YESTERDAY, THIS IS
JUST NOT THE BEST USE --
BASICALLY WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT IS HAVING TO SPEND MONEY
IN GEORGIA TO FEND OFF DONALD
TRUMP'S ATTACKS.
AND HE SAYS THIS IS JUST NOT THE
BEST USE OF OUR MONEY.
WE WOULD MUCH RATHER USE IT IN
RACES AGAINST DEMOCRATS, BUT IT
WAS MADE NECESSARY BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP DECIDED ON THE
VENDETTA TOUR THIS YEAR AND SO
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE PROTECT
THESE FOLKS WHO ARE THE OBJECTS
OF HIS VENGEANCE.
SO WHAT IS THE LARGER POINT
HERE?
>> WELL, THE LARGER POINT IS
CHRIS CHRISTIE IS EXUDING THE
QUAINT NOTION THAT POLITICAL
PARTIES ARE ABOUT THE TEAM AND
THE HEALTH AND FUTURE OF THE
PARTY AS A WHOLE.
HE'S DOING THAT IN THE ERA OF
DONALD TRUMP WHO HAS MADE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ALL ABOUT
HIMSELF.
HE DOESN'T THINK ABOUT IT WOULD
BE BETTER SPENT HERE OR THERE,
HE DOESN'T VIEW THE WORLD
THROUGH THAT LENS.
FORTUNATELY, THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION DECIDED TO
VIEW THE WORLD EXACTLY THROUGH
THAT LENS AND THAT'S THE ROLE OF
A PARTY OR PARTY COMMITTEE, TO
HELP THE INCUMBENTS AND ROCK
STAR OFFICE HOLDERS WIN
ELECTION.
IN GEORGIA THAT'S A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE STACEY ABRAMS IS ONE OF
THE TOP DEMOCRAT RECRUITS IN THE
COUNTRY.
SHE WILL NOT LACK FOR RESOURCES.
SO EVERY DOLLAR WE'VE THROWN
AWAY IN THE USELESS REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY WE COULD HAVE SPENT IN
THE FALL.
THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO LOOK
STRATEGIC WAY TO LOOK AT IT.
I'M GLAD HE'S STANDING UP FOR
THAT POINT OF VIEW BECAUSE IT
STRENGTHENS THE PARTY AND IT
WORKS.
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT CONGRESSMAN
MO BROOKS IS FOLLOWING YOUR
CREED.
HE'S RUNNING FOR SENATE IN
ALABAMA AND HE IS DOING SO BY
GOING AFTER YOUR LONG-TIME BOSS
AND COLLEAGUE, MITCH MCCONNELL.
SO LET ME READ TO YOU WHAT HE
SAYS.
MO BROOKS SAYS ON TWITTER, WE
ONLY HAVE A COUPLE MORE DAYS
UNTIL THE PRIMARY ELECTION.
REMEMBER THIS ELECTION IS A
BATTLE BETWEEN MITCH MCCONNELL
AND THE SWAMP VERSUS GRASSROOTS
CONSERVATIVES.
IS THAT A WINNING STRATEGY?
>> WELL, I MEAN, MO BROOKS'
PROBLEM IS THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
FOR HIM AND NOW HE'S AGAINST HIM
AND BAILED OUT ON HIM AND HE'S
TRYING TO MAKE THIS RACE ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
WINNING STRATEGY.
THAT RACE HAS GOTTEN
INTERESTING, THOUGH.
BROOKS HAD FALLEN BACK AND NOW
THE LATEST POLLING SHOWS HIM
RISING.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE HEADING FOR
A RUNOFF IN ALABAMA.
ALABAMA SENATE IS ONE OF THE
MOST INTERESTING, ONE OF THE
CLOSEST RACES.
IT'S GOT SOME OF THE STRANGEST
DYNAMICS AND REALLY I THINK ONE
OF THE BEST CANDIDATES IN THE
COUNTRY, KAT